yaneka rejoue au bonhomme pendu avec
leur nouvel ami ed de robots qui a élu
domicile au centre d'hébergement armand
lavergne et qui est de mettre un peu de
piquant dans la vie des résidents ça
peut pencher le teint plus vite
que dirait-il tout celle d'un
appartement mais que pas d'activité je
travaille mon esprit il ya besoin
nourriture j'aimerais par et le robot
préfère la lecture avec des résidents on
a décrit son père comme animé des quiz
animé tout ça des quizz avec des
résidents demandé question parce qu'en
effet il parle
que puis-je fait pour lui bonjour culte
si c'est quoi la météo aujourd'hui il
fait tuer mon c degrés avec un temps
nuageux et il marche aussi il s'en va
rejoindre son collègue dans la salle
commune qui se prépare à diffuser un
récital en direct
ayant dans la presse et la cliente
un autre moment de détente et de
divertissement
[Musique]
la soliste qui offre une prestation peut
contrôler le robot à distance
il approchait des résidents pour
interagir dans le cadre du projet pilote
des robots côtoient les résidents d'ems
3 ch à celle des montréalais depuis juin
ça amène toute la personnalisation de
l'offre service loisirs qu'on puisse
avoir une variété beaucoup plus grande
qui vont toucher vraiment
individuellement les résident a promis
j'ai trouvé ça étudiants après tout des
putschs connu ça va bien on vient
concert bitume et comment placer comme
si on était au teil parle que vous
parlez avec un autre personne qui vous
répond le projet pilote se terminera
vers la fin de l'été
si l'expérience est concluante d'autres
robots pourraient emménager dans les
sièges celle des îles ce levier machin
radio canada montréal